hey everyone and welcome to a brief tech
video just tech related stuff i have to
show you guys really quickly if i open
up a web browser right here as you can
see by the title i've discovered that
the new mac minis and imacs are out all
you have to do is go to www.apple.com
and you can either go to
mac which i click on and as you saw on
the front page the new imacs are out and
the new mac minis are out so if i were
to click on the mac mini you'll also see
faster and greener because it's
more um it's more efficient basically
uses less power and it's just as
powerful
faster nvidia graphics and it's extra
small it is just a sweet machine
so that's they're thinking green apple
says 13 wants less so it's 45 less
energy that's quite good and also if
we're going to if we're going there if
we go back to the mac tab and click on
imac
we also see that the max the imacs have
a refresh and there's there's new design
features there's remember um
i life oh nine came out so this is uh
it's all black and nice and matte on the
back it's really sweet
and you can also get aluminum or glass
so it's really really sweet and
if you like the max and if you like mac
os 10 then i will go ahead and say that
these these are the best macs that have
come out this year these are the best
well these are the best macs that have
come out the best desktop refresh i
think the mac pros still have yet to be
refreshed but hey i have one now so
if it does it gets any better you know
i'll check him out but that's basically
all i have to say so thanks for checking
out this video and i hope you like it
peace